can you say something about some of the
details of the software engineering
challenges required to build these
browsers I mean the engineering
challenges of creating a product that
hasn't really existed before that can
have such uh almost like Limitless uh
impact on the world with the internet so
there was a really key bet that we made
at the time which is very controversial
which was quarter core to how it was
engineered which was are we optimizing
for performance um or for ease of
creation yeah and in those days the
pressure was very intense to optimize
for performance because the network
connections were so slow and also the
computers were so slow
um and so if you had I mentioned the
progressive jpeg is like
if if there's an alternate World in
which we optimize for performance and it
just you had just a much more pleasant
experience right up front
but what we got by not doing that was we
got ease of creation and the way that we
got ease of creation was all of the
protocols and formats were in text not
in binary
um and so HTTP isn't text by the way and
this was an internet tradition by the
way that we picked up but we continued
it HTTP is taxed um and uh HTML is
texted and then everybody else
everything else that followed is text
um as a result and by the way you can
imagine purist Engineers saying this is
insane you have very limited bandwidth
why are you wasting any time sending
text you should be encoding the stuff
into binary and it'll be much faster and
of course the answer is that's correct
but what you get when you make it text
is all of a sudden well the big
breakthrough was the view Source
function right so the fact that you
could look at a web page you could hit
view source and you could see the HTML
and that was how people learn how to
make web pages right it's so interesting
because the stuff we would take for
granted now
is uh man that was fundamental to the
development of the web to be able to
have HTML just right there all the
ghetto mess that is HTML all the sort of
almost biological like messiness of HTML
and then having the browser try to
interpret that mess yeah to show
something reasonable well and then there
was this internet principle that we
inherited which was emit what was it
emit cautiously admit conservatively
interpret liberally so it basically
meant if you're in the design principle
was if you're if you're creating like a
web editor that's going to emit HTML
like do it as cleanly as you can but you
actually want the browser to interpret
liberally which is you actually want
users to be able to make all kinds of
mistakes and for it to still work yeah
and so the browser rendering engines to
this day have all of this spaghetti code
crazy stuff where they can they're
resilient to all kinds of crazy HTML
mistakes and so and literally what I
always had in my head is like there's an
eight-year-old or an 11 year old
somewhere and they're doing a view
Source they're doing a cut and paste and
they're trying to make a web page for
their turtle or whatever and like they
leave out a slash and they leave out an
angle bracket and they do this and they
do that and it still works it's it's
also like that I don't often think about
this but you know programming you know C
plus plus CC plus plus all those
languages list but the compiled language
the interpreted language is python Pearl
all that they the brace has to be all
correct yes like everything has to be
perfect brutal
and then autistic you forget all right
it's systematic and rigorous let's go
there but you forget that the uh uh the
web with JavaScript eventually uh and
HTML is allowed to be messy in the way
for the first time
messy in the way biological systems
could be messy it's like the only thing
computers were allowed to be messy on
for the first time it used to offend me
so I I grew up in units I I worked on
Unix I was a Unix native for all the way
through this period um and so and it
used to drive me bananas when it would
do the the segmentation fault and the
chord on file and just like it's you
know it's like literally there's like an
error in the code the math is off by one
yeah and it core dumps yeah and I'm in
the core dump trying to analyze it and
trying to reconstruct what and I'm just
like this is ridiculous like the
computer ought to be smart enough to be
able to know that if it's off by one
okay fine and it keeps running and I
would go ask all the experts like why
can't I just keep running and they'd
explain to me well because all the
downstream repercussions and blah blah
and I'm like they're still like you know
this is we're forcing the human Creator
to live to your point in this hyper
little literal world of perfection yeah
and I was just like that's just that's
just bad and by the way you know because
what happens with that of course just
what happened with with coding at that
point which is you get a high priesthood
you know there's a small number of
people who are really good at doing
exactly that most people can't and most
people are excluded from it and so
actually that was where that for there's
where I picked up that idea was um uh
was like no no you want you want you
want these things to be resilient to
error in all kinds and this this would
drive appearance absolutely crazy like I
got attacked on this like a lot because
yeah I mean like every time I you know
all the purists who were like into all
this like markup language stuff and
formats and codes and all this stuff
they would be like you know you can't
you're encouraging bad behavior because
oh so they wanted the browser to give
you an a sec fault error anytime there
was uh yeah yeah they wanted to be a cop
right they wanted yeah that was a very
any any properly trained credential
engineer would be like that's not how
you build these systems that's such a
bold move to say no it doesn't have to
be yeah now like I said the good news
for me is the internet kind of had that
tradition already
um but we but having said that like we
pushed it we pushed it way out but the
other thing we did going back to the
performance thing was we gave up a lot
of performance we made that initial
experience for the first few years was
pretty painful but but the bet there was
actually an economic bet which was
basically the demand for the web would
basically mean that there would be a
surge in supply of broadband like
because the question was okay how do you
get how do you how do you get the phone
companies which are not famous in those
days for doing new things at huge cost
for like speculative reasons like how do
you get them to build up Broadband you
know spend billions of dollars doing
that and you know you could go meet with
them and try to talk them into it or you
could just have a thing where it's just
very clear that it's going to be that
people love that's going to be better if
it's faster and so that that there there
was a period there and this was this was
fraught with some Peril but there was a
period there where it's like we knew the
experience was sub-optimized because we
were trying to force the emergence of
demand for Broadband sure which is in
fact what happened
so you have to figure out how to display
this text html text
so the Blue Links and the purple links
and there's no standards is there
standards at that time it really still
wasn't
well there's like there's implied
implied standards right and they you
know there's all these cousin new
features that are being added like CSS
what like what kind of stuff a browser
should be able to support features with
the languages within JavaScript and so
on but you you bait you're setting
standards
on the fly yeah yourself well to this
day if you if you create a web page that
has no CSS style sheet the browser will
render it however it wants to yeah right
so this was one of the things there was
this idea this idea at the time and how
these systems were built which is
separation of content from uh format or
separation of uh yeah content from
appearance
um and that's still people don't really
use it anymore because everybody wants
to determine how things look and so they
use CSS but um it's still in there that
you can just let the browser do all the
work I still like the
like uh really basic websites but that
could be just old school kids these days
with their fancy
responsive websites that don't actually
have much content but have a lot of
visual elements well that's one of the
things that's fun about chat you know
about chatgpt yes like back to the
basics back to just text yeah right and
it you know there is this pattern in
human creativity and media where you end
up back at text and I think there's you
know there's something powerful in there